I love this man's at work every single
item that he writes for Yahoo Sports is
a proverbial must read he is one of the
lead colonists and our entire profession
and the sports riding world he's Dan
Wetzel how are you Dan I'm hanging in
there right now Dan
so where do we start on this one where
were you knocked over by the proverbial
to use that phrasing in feather when
NASCAR made the announcement that the
Confederate flag was going to be banned
from all their events well once Bubba
Wallace came out on Sunday and discussed
that the work was pretty quick that
around that NASCAR was gonna follow up
on unofficially trying to ban the flag
from its events now back in 2015 it
stopped allowing the flags use in any
official capacity and then it asked fans
to refrain from bringing the flag so
this wasn't a complete sea change this
is sort of just a bolder statement and
in reality who knows what it really
means how are you going to enforce this
as we know the flag obviously can go see
a flag inning
flown in an infield or campground and
you could go and see that next
Confederate flag is on bumper stickers
and on license plate holders and on
t-shirts and hats and it's in a lot of
places so I think it's a very big
symbolic step for NASCAR but it is one
that may be kind of more symbolic than
anything else and it is one that they've
been moving towards in recent years okay
so what do you think happens now dan
what do you think happens here I know
you you know I saw your comment
yesterday I kind of tagged on to it with
what Jimmy Johnson had to say on the
show yesterday but what do you think
happens next year I think Jimmy Johnson
was very interesting and very
and I think the way that the flat tears
out at these races is if the drivers
choose to be extremely vocal in support
and getting rid of it
because it's the door nope no NASCAR fan
the neck you know hierarchy with the the
president of NASCAR thinks the same way
if roger goodell cope you know access
our fans to do something probably move
over do the opposite what if the drivers
who have the connection with the fans
are unified on this and we'll see if
they are or what they actually believe
on it and you can change kind of the
mindset of the track where it's like
that's not really cool to bring anymore
and it sort of becomes a group thing
then that becomes a much bigger deal Tom
Brady and and Patrick mahomes and those
guys are saying some it carries a lot
more weight than its Roger Goodell does
so that's the same way in this car so
you know if Jimmie Johnson and and all
the drivers are saying you know if you
fly that flag on route for me if you fly
that flag you're hurting our sport
you're hurting the future of our
business to see whether we keep this
thing going there's a lot NASCAR's out
of the best of business trends anyway
and try to use their their ability to
connect with fans to just explain that
this we're not trying to take something
away from you or whatever they well I
don't know how they want to put it but
it's more about not being rude being
more welcoming trying to create more
fans like rethink how you feel about
this flag I think that's when you could
have significant impact so what Jimmy
said on your show and I wasn't surprised
Jimmy said that but it was significant
because you haven't heard through the
years this overwhelming support from
from drivers willing to step out and
eventually go basically go against some
segment of their fan base will they be
that aggressive I think that's going to
be the next step in how important this
goes well you if I'm not mistake
about a decade plus ago brought this
issue up to as many drivers as you could
and what junior was the only one who
would address it when you spoke to them
yeah I looked at stirring up last night
I I mean I remembered it but I hadn't
looked at long time 2006 I went and you
know I covered some NASCAR and you know
if you're not from the South I've spent
a lot of time to South but if you're not
from the South you drive under a track
and it you know and in a lot of these
tracks for certainly in the south
and back then I mean there was so many
flats and it's it's jarring and I you
know you just go wow like I just didn't
I didn't know it'd be this this many
flags in one spot and so I we decided to
kind of ask around I said you know what
do you think like this is NASCAR taken a
position already that they really
weren't in favor of this and made much
of a statement but clearly some people
are are going to look at it and say this
is not you know I don't want to be a
part of this or I you know you're an
african-american family and you pull up
to the infield I said I'm going the
other direction you know what what's
your opinion of this why do you think
this is appropriate you think this is
welcoming and literally every single
driver every single team denied comment
or told me if I even asked it at a group
session it'll be shut down and they'll
do this it was aggressively opposed to
even discussing this
Dale Earnhardt jr. to his credit did he
was the only one who was willing to talk
about it and I mean I was about 40
drivers at the time and that's so that
to me is how far this has come because
you now see in 14 years not only they
discussing it a lot of worse cussing it
you know pretty openly with some depth
with some understanding of I need to
learn more about this I don't expect
every NASCAR driver to be up on every
single issue but the openness to it I
think it's a complete sea change because
you went from like why are you asking
this question he'll know we're not
talking about this too I imagine
almost any NASCAR driver on your show
today to discuss it
so that's a big change in those 14 years
Dan Wetzel of Yahoo Sports here on the
Rich Eisen show I haven't heard any from
other than just did that statement that
I read from NASCAR any of the top
management members of of NASCAR the the
families that are atop the flowchart
there why do you think they have made
this maneuver because you know obviously
it is it is it is you know right now
something everybody is talking about you
see polling that black lives matter as a
movement has reached a pinnacle I mean
and it keeps going up in terms of people
who support what they believe black
lives have had her tube to be and so the
question is is where did the France
family make the same read of the room in
a way or is this truly because because
when fans come back that's when I guess
to use the phrase rubber will meet the
road on this don't you think or if they
come back look this is a bit you know
let's I you know I sound heartless or
ignorant but you know if you take the
politics or let's do the right thing or
whatever equation you want you look at
this simply as business this is a a
risky business move by last line that's
why it's held clearly the direction the
country is going quickly but certainly
with the traditional change in the
direction of I don't want to be I don't
want to be watching a race next sort of
confederate flag okay and and that that
is moving however there is still a
sizable segment of the NASCAR fan base
that does NASCAR does not have a good
billion chance
NASCAR can't fill it stands now it can't
reach the television ratings that used
to reach now and so if you sit there and
say well you know maybe the NFL can go
look we're gonna write off 20 percent of
our fans at 10 percent of our fans
whatever number it is on the short term
because we know people under 35 are
sporting this that you know 70% rate or
something like that's the future of our
business for NASCAR you're losing the
little of what you will lose some of
what you already have and there's no
promise that all sudden people are going
to become NASCAR fans no I do believe
that there are people who don't go to
races because it's an unwelcoming
environment due to the flag how many of
those people are there I don't know I
don't think anybody knows but it
certainly makes sense to assume that so
for a NASCAR there is a risk here
because there is a a sizable segment
that that right or wrong does not see
this flag as offensive season as you
know heritage not hate it is a
significant argument often many of these
people and that's how they feel and if
they're going to give up on NASCAR
NASCAR does loss some of the most loyal
people so it's all more complicated it's
very very easy for us to sit back hey
NASCAR should have done this but you
know are you going to start covering
NASCAR every week now you know are you
going to go to a race other people
applauding this on social media go to
salsa
tune in do they watch last night in
Martinsville or they just don't really
like on auto racing very very
interesting business concept of trying
to decide this and unfortunately you
know what the fallout will be we'll see
are there are those people really never
going to watch a race again or are they
just saying that I've been watching race
again and a couple weeks they'll start
watching well I'll find out I guess we
will and then I guess in the in the
immediate future here
racist Sorrell he's about to get his 15
minutes and well I I mean he's a 50-year
old and I say that as a 50 year old a 50
year old NASCAR truck driver who's I'm
looking up right here his best finish I
guess the 30 15 thirty third place 17
races saying that he's he's out over
this issue because
people who do love the Confederate flag
it doesn't make them racist and he still
doesn't believe people kneeling on the
national anthem these are two items that
are at the forefront of one of the most
talked-about Twitter accounts on Twitter
I think I can I can easily say that that
mr. Ciccarelli is going to probably wind
up on the president's Twitter feed very
shortly so will there be other drivers
you think that may follow suit or or
what do you think that will immediate
reaction is going to be a very low level
driver almost no one's ever heard of
races around I believe it's 17 races are
over these are over years in a race at
all this year this is not a cup level
driver so this is not one of your major
guys that's racing on Sundays so this is
by no means a commonest person it would
be like a minor leaguer saying that and
so he has his opinion and I do agree
that his opinion is certainly reflective
of some segment of the made this is the
the cust Cup level or the fan base or
whatever so I don't want to dismiss just
dismiss it out of hand it's one guy but
this is not a major driver well he's
about to become major and more prominent
Dan you know that as you and I are both
yourself into it but the reality is
you're talking about a minor league
driver who has been washed up and not
doing anything saying saying I quit well
nobody had you driving this year anyway
if this was an NFL or NBA player in the
nation knew who it was they would try
laughs there's laughter statement out so
it just wasn't I'm you know if this was
if Jimmy Johnson's on your show you're
saying I'm quitting I'm never driving
again you know wait at six-time champ
this is hope that's big deal he isn't so
do the major nobody is a fan of this guy
he's not followers now will he get some
now I guess but this was not a
significant driver so you can look up
this guy I don't know his race in total
but he's never won
now I don't think he's ever had a pole I
don't think he's ever been in the top 10
this is not advocate time guy so what
again is there some segment do you lose
some workers you lose some people use
some fast I think it would be most
likely and ask are well can they get
more by creating a different race day
environment by making this dance we'll
see it's tricky because I don't know I
just don't know how pop if this is an
issue for you like are you now our
people now sit there saying oh I wasn't
a race fan because of this but now I'm
really going to get into stock car
racing I don't know that's the that's
the great business equation of this
really interesting to see because it's
not like football or basketball where
you say well look the younger people are
gonna be on our side we may take a hit
for a little while but we're going to
come back bigger or something like that
this is just a totally different but
until you create the mindset but this is
good for the sport this is the right
thing to do this is the courteous thing
and you get the driver to do that you
know that'll be the key for NASCAR going
forward it can't just be while we banned
it people are still going to have the
flag there in some someway and you know
if you have to change the hearts not
just the policy Dan Wetzel Yahoo Sports
here on the Rich Eisen show before I let
you go Dan what do you want that's the
first item up for bids for for the
football world we're seeing more and
more institutions of higher learning
saying uh players can come back to
campus and start participating in
practices so on and so forth what are
you hearing about this 2020 playing
season talk to atletic directors and
commissioners and things like that just
it's a sea change from two months ago
and you know I think one of the things
everyone else said we don't have to make
a decision now we got until June late
June pride July first we have to make a
decision but certainly what looked very
very dire back in March and April now
says hey
seems to be possible we have a much
better understanding of the virus once
we started taking it seriously so I have
a pretty good confidence that every
school will start the season and I did
not think that in March I thought some
might but it seems like everyone's going
to start whether they can finish I don't
know at the same time is we don't it's
hard to predict out two months it's even
harder to pick out four but there's
great confidence that they'll be able to
start that in some places you could even
have full stadiums but certainly
twenty-five to fifty percent and if you
had given college football that does
that deal back on life you know April
one they would have taken it in a
heartbeat because they were looking at
empty stadiums or no games or limited
games so I think there's been a
tremendous push forward now obviously
we're still a long way from the season
so a lots got a lot of positivity at the
stay with us but I would expect college
football gets played September well I
mean I just there might be more stomach
for it because you're seeing spikes and
like I guess you're seeing 25 states
from what I heard last four I saw this
on on on TV last night through NBC News
that 25 states are experiencing lower
hospitalization rates over the last 25
weeks and that's up from 16 but more
states are now experiencing higher
hospitalization rates than two weeks ago
as well there's now 19 states that are
experiencing more hospitalization rates
so again we have to take a look at the
virus and boots on the ground but there
definitely appears to be for all sports
every last sport more of a stomach of
saying we're gonna deal with people
testing positive and not shut things
down and figure out a protocol with
therapeutics so on and so forth to move
this thing forward but you know these
are also sports that have to negotiate
with a union as we're seeing with with
baseball with college sports is just
like okay we're letting kids on campus
so let's play and there's gonna be some
schools that can
I think what what afford to even get on
a plane or a bus or or or or or hold
this stuff or you know it's not it's
gonna be more of the haves than the
have-nots don't you think Dan when it
all comes down to it I think though I'll
try to play ok I think that the the two
aspects were gonna stand in the way of
playing was local health officials like
if this was a very regionalized
decisions so one county somewhere could
say no and and then all of a sudden it's
like I just get out you know just
holding out feelings and the whole thing
kind of can collapse and you're gonna
end up with like a limited season right
now we're not seeing that in the country
again we're a long way from September as
you mentioned hospitalization rates go
up down all sorts of things we don't
know I'm not the person to tell you
what's gonna happen with a virus so
absolutely the other big one was they
had to get over the concept whether this
is a good idea back up to you to decide
that if one player tests positive that
doesn't mean the team is shut down in
quarantine because if that was going to
be the standard which for a little while
it just kind of felt like that's the
standard there was no way you could
start because somebody a group of
hundred something people because you
have the sports that the coach isn't
elderly coaches we have all sorts of
problems they're going to get it I mean
it's just it'd be impossible to try to
believe you could run a football season
and I thought college football was the
single hardest sport in America to try
this because you have a hundred and
thirty Division One teams right in 43
states and you've got all different you
have military academies private schools
public schools religious schools
everyone's playing this way so could we
do it but I do think that once that it's
believed hey we got a couple we'll put
them to the side it's gonna be alright
we're gonna keep going cuz only that
mind sets there you push through and
then as long as the local health
officials aren't saying this school
can't play but this school can you can
keep some formation of what this season
isn't you're not just saying oh we're
going to play Saturday but now we can
and it all falls apart
I think they're gonna try it there's a
lot of optimism there's also a lot of
desperation these schools have looked at
the bottom line of what happens if there
is an AFOL ziza race or what happens if
there's not a fall semester and look at
higher education and college sports
obviously our businesses and they're in
a lot of trouble if they don't do this
so I think they're all gonna push
forward yeah I think Chris when we had
Brian Kelly on a couple weeks ago right
from Notre Dame talking about his
schedule that includes trips to Ireland
which as we all know has now been made a
home game for Navy in in Maryland and
then you know it's kind of like a United
Nations of schedules everybody's on it
right it's like pac-12 s on it Big Ten's
on it tons of ACC is on it and I asked
him about you know the schedule and and
how trying to get some sort of
uniformity of everybody like what are
the odds that everybody's gonna be in
and his schedule is gonna stay intact
and he said you know something along the
lines of we may have to play Navy you
know at Navy but if the check clears
Western Michigan's gonna be at our place
didn't he say that Chris he sure did if
the check clears Western Michigan B here
is essentially what he said yeah yeah
well you're right he's right look they
can say all sorts of stuff at the end of
the day that checks got to be there and
so they're gonna they they're gonna do
this they're gonna try the issue of
course can you finish right that's gonna
be the question right what's going on in
November
anybody who can sit there and say that
Ohio State Michigan game 100% that's
happening in a hundred thousand people
in front of horseshoes they're lying to
you they don't know nobody knows that I
oh so we all hope so do we though Dan do
we I hope the virus is not a big deal we
get to watch Ohio State okay Michigan
play I hope the buyer I hope we come up
with a cure I don't know me too again
I'm not your virus guy but I know
talking to these babies and these
coaches it's like no we got to do this
and they're gonna try so nobody can
predict too far out and it's why I say I
think they're gonna try to start I don't
know whether they can finish but they're
gonna want to try to start and you know
look if there's a huge surge in July
maybe well start but as it's going right
now and I haven't I'm not up on the on
the infection rate percentages right
there's a lot of optimism that yeah
we're going to do this and Western
Michigan they're saying if we don't get
whatever million a couple million bucks
are getting from Notre Dame
how do we how do we have X number of
sports how do we do this and I guess the
Western Michigan budget is reliant on
them play right a Brian Kelly's right
yeah and I guess one more for you then
dan I appreciate as long as you've given
me right now what about the future and
and and the fact that if some
conferences can't go or some smaller
schools can't go won't go don't have the
ability to go do you think that this is
a pop there's a possibility that the Big
Five may emerge from all of this as just
a separate entity in college football
you know that the big five plus one when
I guess Notre Dame would be just a
separate entity that they're just gonna
schedule themselves and that's the end
of that and there's just gonna be
smaller schools big schools and they'll
figure it out from there is that a
possibility do you think it gets a lot
of attention as a possibility I just
simply don't believe it's pop but it's
true because what's the motivation to do
that right now you know if you want to
talk Notre Dame the Chicago Bears play
16 games and eight of them are home and
eight of a bar loan code Notre Dame well
Notre Dame is not a good example though
they play all these games all over the
place but whatever they get eight home
games and four on the road Michigan
let's take Michigan and the Detroit
Lions University Michigan is playing
seven to eight home games a year four to
five road games do you want to give that
up to go 5050
you're losing money so they already get
all the money from college football
almost all the money and they can do
by having Western Michigan and all these
other schools pretend that they're in
their leak and they can fill up their
stadium and make a ton of money so there
is a financial benefit to having these
smaller schools they have to share the
basketball tournament revenue with those
those leaks but they still get the vast
majority of it
and the basketball tournament would not
be nearly as as popular without smaller
schools an underdog creating the kind of
sweep up America sentiment and you
wouldn't have major markets in the
Northeast and things like that like
Villanova and Georgetown have battered
it boost you up so right now those those
five power conferences and really it's
two to three of them and Notre Dame get
all the money already what's the
motivation to kick Western Michigan out
they're not really reigning you they're
actually making new money so I just
don't see it as a financial thing of
saying let's boot these guys out because
we're getting extra home games because
of this completely ridiculous system we
have going excel style structure now
it's 50/50 we're not getting what we're
getting less home games dan thanks for
the call great column as always that
sparked my call to yours to your to your
phone and we appreciate the time let's
chat again soon man be well appreciate
about thank you god it's Dan Wetzel he's
one of the best men guy knows how to
write he knows that a report he knows
how to put it together he knows how to
opinion ight ight I really appreciate
have a great chat right there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here